[MUSIC PLAYING]
JACOB SOVIERO: I'd
like to take a second
and talk to you about somebody.
This gentleman served
in the active duty
in the United States Army
for three years from 2003
until 2006.
He served at the 3rd
Battalion 21st Infantry
Regiment, an element of the
1st brigade, 25th Infantry
Division.
October, 2004, he was
deployed to Mosul, Iraq
to support Operation
Iraqi Freedom.
Currently, he serves at the
National Veteran Liaison
for Project Welcome Home Troops,
a program of International
Association over Human Values.
He also travels around the
country giving intro talks,
organizing, and assisting,
and teaching the power breath
method, workshops for veterans,
their families, and active duty
military.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome Tom Voss.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
And we're actually
lucky enough today.
Tom is actually going to lead
us in a little bit of the power
breath method that you saw
at the end of the film, which
I thought was fantastic.
So without further ado, Tom.
TOM VOSS: Yeah, thanks
for everyone coming.
This is really great to
see you all of you showing
up and watching my life.
It's pretty strange for
me, so thanks for coming.
But first thing we
thought we would do
is just teach you a little
bit of some intro breathing
techniques.
So what we're going
to learn is called
alternate nostril breathing.
It sounds just like what it is.
All we're going to be doing
is breathing alternately
through each nostril.
It has a nice calming effect.
This is something that you can
do if you have high anxiety
or you're feeling a
little bit nervous.
It's just a nice, quick
breathing technique.
So what we're going
to be doing is
we're going to be
taking our index finger
and our middle
finger, and we're just
going to be placing them
in between our eyebrows
right here.
It's pretty simple.
And then we're going to take
our thumb and ring finger,
and these two are actually going
to be the ones that are going
to be closing off our nostrils.
So what we're all
going to do first
is take a normal breath
in through our nose,
and breathe out
through the nose.
Let's do that one more time.
Breathing in through the
nose and exhaling out.
So now, what we're going to
do is close our right nostril
with our thumb, and inhale
through the left nostril.
Switching, exhaling
out through the right.
In through the right,
and now through the left.
And you can close your eyes, if
you're comfortable doing that.
In through the left, and
out through the right.
Now, you can just continue
on your own at your own pace,
taking nice deep breaths.
[DEEP BREATHS]
See if you can make the
breaths just a little deeper.
And keeping the eyes closed,
you can drop your hand.
Just rest it in your lap.
Return to normal breathing.
I want you to think
of one thing that you
are grateful for in your life.
And slowly and gradually,
you may open your eyes
at your own pace.
OK.
How's everyone doing?
Good?
How was that?
Cool.
Awesome.
I think after that, we're ready
to start the discussion panel
in a nice, more grounded space.
I know that film can be a
little intense at times,
but I'm glad you all made it.
JACOB SOVIERO: So
without further ado,
I'd like to bring up
the rest of the panel,
and I'll bring
them up one by one.
I'm going to quickly
read their bios.
Dr. Bayley is a neuroscientist
at the War Related Illness
and Injury Study Center
at the VA Palo Alto
and assistant professor in
the Department of Psychiatry
and Behavioral
Sciences at Stanford.
His research interests include
rehabilitation treatments
for chronic pain, post-traumatic
stress disorder using
integrative interventions,
such as yoga and meditation.
He takes a cognitive
neuroscience perspective
to investigate, to explore
their mechanisms of action
and how they relate to both
mental and psychological
functioning.
Dr. Peter Bayley.
[APPLAUSE]
Next, joining us is
Dr. Natalie Purcell.
Natalie is a sociologist
and researcher
in the Department of Social
and Behavioral Sciences
at the University of
California, San Francisco.
And she was currently the
patient-centered care program
director at the San Francisco
VA Health Care System.
In her role at the
VA, Dr. Purcell
works to improve
veterans' health
care by promoting personalized
patient-driven care planning
and expanding the range of
integrative health and wellness
resources available to veterans.
Dr. Purcell's research focuses
on the impact of violence
and moral injury in the
lives of our veterans
and on the effectiveness
of integrative health care
intervention for veterans.
Dr. Purcell.
[APPLAUSE]
Dr. Maguen is a mental health
director of the OEF Integrated
Care Clinic and
staff psychologist
on the post-traumatic
stress disorder
clinical team at the San
Francisco VA Medical Center.
Her research interests
fall under the umbrella
of PTSD, moral
injury, and suicide,
and include risk and
resilience factors
in veterans with a particular
focus on female veterans.
Dr. Maguen was a recipient of
the VA Health Services Research
and Development
grant that examined
the impact of
killing in veterans
of war and moral injury.
She also works in a clinical
capacity within the OEF
Integrated Care Clinic
treating veterans
with evidence-based
treatments for PTSD.
Dr. Shira Maguen.
[APPLAUSE]
And we also have Michael Collins
joining us from the team.
We've already given
his bio, so I'm not
going to talk about that.
Thank you for joining.
So without further ado, I'd
like to kick the panel off.
And I think the first best
question that we could probably
ask is this one.
We see a gentleman
sitting up here
that we've seen on screen, maybe
with a bit less of a beard.
But I'm sure we'd all
like to know, Tom,
could you tell us a little
bit about what's been going on
in your life since the film?
TOM VOSS: Yeah, a lot, actually.
I've been traveling around with
the film doing talks like this
and also organizing
workshops for veterans.
So the power breath
meditation workshop
that you saw in the film is--
Project Welcome Home
Troops as an organization
that I volunteer for, and
it's something, as you saw,
that had a huge
impact in my life.
And before taking
that workshop, you
wouldn't have caught me dead in
a yoga and/or breathing class.
But you know, I was
to a point where
I was able to try anything
to kind of feel better
and to move forward
with my life.
So it has had a
tremendous impact on me,
and I'm just trying to share
that with as many veterans
and civilians alike.
JACOB SOVIERO: That's
awesome. thank you.
TOM VOSS: Thank you.
JACOB SOVIERO: So I'd
like to actually start.
We saw that a little bit
in the end in the film.
We talked about PTSD and
moral injury, moral dilemma,
and the difference
between the two.
I'm having, Dr. Maguen, could
you tell us a little bit more
about the relationship
between PTSD and moral injury?
SHIRA MAGUEN: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
Well, first, I want
to just say that I
think PTSD is more
of a diagnosis,
so that's really
important to recognize,
whereas moral injury is more
something that we think about
on a continuum.
It's a problem that
people face, but one
that is not a diagnosis.
And as we saw in the
film, it's really
about feeling like you
crossed over some line that
goes against your--
that you went against your own
moral beliefs and expectations
and that, as a
result, you're really
having some struggles or some
inner conflict in relation
to that.
So when we think
about PTSD, PTSD
is really made up of
several different symptoms.
And so with PTSD,
you really think
about a person having
re-experiencing symptoms,
meaning they're having
nightmares or dreams about what
happened to them as an example.
They also avoid in a
great respect reminders
of what happened to them while
they were deployed, reminders
of the emotional experience
that they might have felt,
so if they felt fear
or guilt or shame,
they try to avoid
those emotions as well.
And then, the third
part of PTSD is arousal,
and so you saw in the
film that difficulty
with anger or difficulty falling
asleep or feeling like you
were just on constant alert or
that you were easily startled.
And so those three pieces
really make up PTSD.
In addition to that,
people also sometimes
have thoughts
about what they did
or what they experience that can
cause them to really feel down
or to want to isolate.
With moral injury,
again, the idea
is that you have crossed some
line and that as a result,
really, you feel some deep guilt
and some deep shame, possibly,
and also some isolation.
And in addition to
that, there is a failure
to be able to forgive
yourself for what you did.
And so I think that that was
really very nicely highlighted
in the film that the
struggle was really
with how you saw yourself
as a person and a struggle
with the failure to forgive,
and once that was tackled,
it really helped the person
to cross that line and heal.
And in many cases, we see
that with many of the veterans
that we work with as well.
And so I think that, really,
if we think about it as a Venn
diagram, you can have PTSD,
and you can have moral injury.
And those things do
have a lot of overlap,
but you can also have
PTSD without moral injury
and moral injury
without PTSD as well.
And so I think that, again,
if we think about PTSD
with really having PTSD as
a result of something that
happened to you--
being exposed to a lot of
IEDs, a lot of explosions,
your body is on alert--
that's more what
PTSD looks like.
And moral injury is more about
guilt and shame and a failure
to forgive oneself that
can really lead to things
that we saw in the film like
suicide, like sabotaging
your relationships.
And sometimes that
inner conflict,
that once you find
that inner peace,
things can go very,
very differently.
So hopefully, that helps
with clarifying the two
to a little bit--
to a greater extent.
JACOB SOVIERO:
Thank you very much.
This is one I'd like to
actually open up to the panel.
During World War
II, our veterans
were welcomed home
with parades, confetti.
Everybody knows the
famous V-J picture,
where sailor's kissing
his lovely lady
in the middle of Times Square.
But now our veterans come
home to racial tension,
political unrest, and
an unknown future.
What kind of effect
does this now
have on our veterans as
opposed to when we were
coming home in World War II?
I'd live to hear from anybody.
TOM VOSS: That's a nice fun.
Anyone want to take it?
I mean, I can talk from
the veteran's perspective
a little bit.
I mean, for me, me coming
home was difficult for me,
because when I got back
from my deployment,
I was out of active
duty within two months.
So I came home
from a combat zone,
and then two months later,
I was back home in Wisconsin
sitting on my mom's couch.
And it was surreal for me
to see that my friends were
doing the exact same things that
they were doing when I left.
And I had this awesomely
terrifying experience of war.
And so I had no one
to connect with,
and then you start seeing the--
I remember just coming home and
seeing how many advertisements
there were, and that
just, like, blew me away.
I was like, wow, everyone
was running around,
and everything was so much
faster when I came back.
So there's this big disconnect
within myself to really--
I just felt like I couldn't--
there's no way I can connect
with anyone, because no one's
going to understand what
I've just been through.
So I think that on
top of that, you
see the social unrest and
the things that are going on.
At least for me, it
was like, OK, we're
over here fighting these
wars, and then we come back,
and it's just like as turbulent,
if not worse, back home.
So then that pulls
into question,
what was I participating in?
What was I doing?
And I know that
Anthony's turning point
was when he was a
convoy commander,
and he was driving across.
He was escorting a
convoy across Iraq,
and when he got to where
he was going-- like,
literally driving across
the whole country of Iraq--
he asked the driver of the semi
truck, what are you guys doing?
What are you guys hauling?
They're like, oh, nothing.
We're just making a
quota for our run.
And that's when he started
questioning, what are we doing?
What am I doing right now?
Like I'm risking my guy's
life, so they can make
a quota for their contract.
So there's a lot of
internal questioning
that goes on, at least
for me when I come home.
JACOB SOVIERO: Thank you.
PETER BAYLEY: Speaking from
a non-veteran perspective,
but something that
I hear from veterans
is there's a huge
amount of training that
goes into training to be a
soldier, something that you
touched on in the documentary--
this many months of over
and over repetitive
muscle memory
that can really ingrained.
And when you're coming
back, when you're returning,
there's no training
how to turn that off.
You're sort of back in society.
There's no untraining of that,
and so I hear from the veterans
that I work with that that's a
basic problem, that there isn't
the understanding
of how to untrain,
if that's the right word.
Or people often use
the word "extinction"
in the more cognitive level--
how to extinguish that, and
that's one of the dynamics.
JACOB SOVIERO: Great.
Thank you.
So one of the things we just
heard about a little bit
was just about some
of those tension, that
feeling when you come back, and
some of those anxiety feelings
that you have.
So some of the symptoms
of PTSD are often
expressed through the
body, things like increased
heart rate and hypervigilance.
What are some of the
alternative treatment
methods that are studying
and training right now?
Dr. Bayley, we'd love
to hear from you.
PETER BAYLEY: So some of
the alternative treatments
is-- well, one of
them is just what
we saw at the very end
of that documentary,
where the power breath, or
Sudarshan Kriya Yoga, is used.
That's still in an
experimental stage.
We're actually running a
clinical trial right now
at the VA in Palo
Alto comparing that
to the best practice
in clinical medicine,
comparing its effectiveness.
Some of the other known
nonstandard treatments
are things like acupuncture.
That's also fairly widely used.
And biofeedback is another one,
biofeedback using, perhaps,
stimuli that are eliciting
some of the anxiety
or the symptoms
of PTSD and trying
to pair it up with a more
relaxation kind of a response.
These kind of things are
really still in their infancy.
Yoga is one other type
of treatment as well.
Again, it's not as widely used
a treatment as you might think.
It sounds like a good
treatment, and there
was some preliminary
evidence to say it is.
But it's lacking in large
trials to really show
that that's as effective as some
of the other treatments that
are currently available.
JACOB SOVIERO: Thank you.
No, it's amazing that we're
looking outside the box
and trying to search
for new answers.
I would like to ask,
actually, Dr. Purcell, what
are some of the
things in programs
that the VA has in action
to support or veterans
struggling with PTSD
and moral injury?
And what advice can you give
to those veterans that are
looking and seeking for help?
NATALIE PURCELL:
Well, I was really
struck at the end
of the movie, Tom,
when you actually spoke
to Congress about this,
about advocating for
meditation to become
a part of the services
that the VA offers.
And I think, increasingly,
at a national level,
there's a recognition
at VA that we really
need to increase the range of
complimentary and integrative
health services that are
available to veterans.
And there's a
commitment to a vision
of care called Whole Health.
In a national presentation from
the Office of Patient-Centered
Care and Cultural Transformation
about the direction
that the VA is going
in for the future,
there's a quote from Plato
that really sticks with me
and, I think, really captures
where the VA is headed.
And I hope I remember
the quote correctly,
but it's something
to the effect of,
you shouldn't attempt
to cure the eyes
without the head or the head
without the body, so nor should
you attempt to cure the
body without the soul,
because the part can never be
well unless the whole is well.
And so there's an increasing
recognition that we really
need to deliver a kind of care
that gets at the whole person,
at the physical, at
the psychological,
at the biological,
at the social,
and at the spiritual level.
And at the VA, we're really
working to improve access
to the range of programs
that really touch
on those different aspects
of veterans' experiences
and their lives.
Right now, actually,
as we're sitting here,
we have four physicians from the
San Francisco VA Medical Center
who are in Los Angeles
getting training
in battlefield acupuncture.
And we've been working to
build community partnerships
with organizations like our
YMCA and even our local San
Francisco SPCA to bring programs
like our strength and wellness
program with yoga and Tai
Chi, animal-assisted therapy
programs to veterans,
so really opening up
the range of treatment
options that are available.
And one thing that I
just want to mention
is as we saw in the film,
there is no such thing
as a one size fits all solution
for PTSD or moral injury
or the wide range of experiences
and struggles that veterans
face when they come back.
And it's important to
recognize that there
is this sort of range of
options that are available
and that you have the
opportunity, if one
thing doesn't work, reach out.
Try something else.
Don't give up.
JACOB SOVIERO:
Thank you very much.
So one question I
had for the panel.
How do gender and race play
into the likelihood of veterans
deciding to seek
help with the VA
or elsewhere for the first time?
SHIRA MAGUEN: I think
there is incredible shame
and stigma associated to
seeking any kind of treatment.
And so I think that's
the first thing
to remember across
race, across gender.
And so I think that it was
incredibly brave of Tom
to go out there
and tell his story.
And you know, it's incredible to
be able to witness that for all
of us, for him to share
all of that with us,
and that's not a
common situation.
And so I think
that a piece of it
is really recognizing how
profound the stigma is
in all of veterans, who may--
there are a lot of barriers
to seeking care
and to getting help
and to reaching
out and even saying
that you might need help.
And so I think that
that's the first piece.
And so I know that there
are a lot of people
in the audience who are
veterans, who know veterans,
who love veterans.
You might be a boyfriend, a
girlfriend, a wife, a partner,
a good friend.
And so I think the first
piece of that is also
thinking across
gender and race lines
in terms of what we can all
do in terms of the community
to really help reach out
and support veterans, who
need care to get care.
So I think that's
the first thing.
I think in terms of race
and gender specifically,
the VA is actually doing a
lot to recognize that there
are similarities in
people, who need care,
and there are also differences.
And so the things that we
can do to specifically help
women to get to the
VA are very important,
because predominantly,
in the past,
it's been the VA has felt
more comfortable to some men
than to women.
And so I think
just having images
on our walls of
women who have served
goes a long way in really--
and we have a women's clinic, in
particular, where women can go,
where they can get
care separate from men
and also be integrated in
their care with men as well.
In terms of race
and ethnicity, I
think being sensitive to the
ways in which race can affect
someone's military service
and the certain degrees
of discrimination that
people might face.
And that can be a
part of the trauma
that they experience
as well, so just
being really aware
of that in their care
can be very, very important, so.
JACOB SOVIERO: Thank you.
So I'd like to ask Michael
a question quickly.
How have you seen the
responses to the film,
obviously, leading up to
PBS coming on Veterans Day?
How have you seen the
responses to the screenings,
and what kind of things have
you taken away from them?
MICHAEL COLLINS: Well,
we've been touring with them
for about a year
and a half, and I
have to say every
audience is different.
But I think what
keeps me going is
that so many of the responses
are just so emotional.
You know, I think the
civilian response has been
one of the most surprising.
We really thought we were making
this film to give veterans
and their families
hope that there
were other paths of healing,
if they felt like they had
exhausted everything
sort of clinically that
was out there, that there
were these other kind of paths
of healing.
But it's a lot of the
civilians coming up and saying,
I had no idea.
Now, I want to go and
talk to my neighbor
and say something besides,
thank you for your service.
Like it's breaking
down some barriers,
I'm noticing, in people.
It's just creating a
connection in audiences,
and it's different.
When I play to an
audience of Vietnam vets,
it's very different when
it's college students.
And every single
time, it's different,
but every single
time, yeah, there's
just something that I
learned that I take away
and that I'm seeing people
are saying the same thing.
And then they're wanting
to, then, take the film
and bring it back home and
bring it to their community
and things like that.
So we've been working to try
to figure out ways to do that,
to make the film
available for everyone.
And we have some ways that
I can talk about after.
JACOB SOVIERO: Fantastic.
Thank you.
And Tom, how about yourself?
How have you seen
these screenings
that you've been a part of?
How have they grown?
TOM VOSS: I mean, I think that
the most impact that I have
is talking to folks
like you, really
seeing how they may or
may not have shifted
your idea about what
veterans are going through,
what their families
are going through.
And I have veterans that
come up to me afterwards,
and they're like,
now, I'm going to go
hike the Appalachian Trail.
That's what I need to do.
I know it now.
And I'm like, that's great.
You should probably ask your
wife, but that's awesome.
So I support it, but yeah.
So it's really cool to see
how you guys all take it in,
and when you guys
have questions,
that's the best part of it.
And Anthony-- the
same with Anthony,
really just connecting,
because with us coming home,
and this is what Anthony
he talks about a lot
and he touched on in
the film is having
trust in the community
when you come back.
And for us to be able to get up
in front of a bunch of people
that we don't know and really
trust you with our story
and what we went through
was a big step for us to do.
And now, it's easier and
easier, and it kind of
keeps me going to be
able to share my story
and know that I can let some
veteran out there, whether it's
one or a pair, that they're
not the only ones that
are going through this.
And coming home, I felt so
isolated being in Wisconsin.
Only active duty guy to get
out of my platoon at that time,
so all my buddies are
getting ready to go
on their second deployment.
It's really-- it's
been a long journey,
and I am really thankful
that it came out
the way that it has so far.
JACOB SOVIERO: Thanks for that.
So you actually started on
the next portion of the night,
because we actually want
to take some questions
from the audience.
So if you have a question,
please raise your hand.
Myself or Amy's going to
come around and give you
a microphone, and then
you can ask a question.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: All right, Tom, so
the trek ended, obviously,
a few years ago, right?
Is there anybody
that you encountered
during the trek that,
looking back now with maybe
a little more clarity
or whatnot, had a bigger
impact on you that you
didn't notice at the time,
while you were on the trek
that maybe wasn't in the movie,
and you would want to
talk about for a minute?
TOM VOSS: Sure.
There's a lot of people.
I mean, there's a
lot of stories that
happened while Michael
and Marty weren't
there, which is unfortunate.
But They were like,
oh, missed it.
But there are a few
examples I can give
you is that we met a pastor.
His name was Pastor Marty.
He was in the Marine Corps and
got out and became a rancher,
and then became a pastor--
super interesting guy.
But he came and brought us
water while we were walking,
and we had water points
kind of mapped out.
And he came and took
us out to dinner.
And what he said to us is he's
like, where you are-- he says,
life demands a response.
And he's like, and you
have to figure out what
your response is going to be.
And then for me, I'm like, OK,
am I even responding or am I
just being dragged
through the mud?
So that was a huge shift
for me and Anthony.
And then what Anthony
and I would do
is we'd talk about that
stuff while we were walking,
so that's when peer
support comes in,
where we have this
shared experience,
and we can kind of process
this stuff together.
So that was a really,
really impactful one for us.
And then one more
is we had a man
stop on the side of the road
to give us $20 to go get lunch.
And he said his brother
died in Vietnam.
So Anthony always likes to talk
about how impactful war is,
that this man had no idea who we
were, had no connection to us,
but he thought he was just
going to stop and help,
because his brother was killed
in Vietnam 40, 45 years ago.
So that just shows
how detrimental war
is to us as human beings.
So it's like it's not
just an isolated event.
It just doesn't affect
the veteran or families.
It affects their community.
It affects generations.
Anthony says, I'm going
to impart the lessons
that I've learned from
Iraq on my daughter.
So it's like, we have to start
looking at that framework,
because then you see
how impactful it is.
So it's generations upon
generations upon generations.
You look at the displaced people
all over the world right now.
How is that going to
impact their kids?
impact the communities
that they're refugees in?
So you just see the
grand scale of this
and how it impacts
us on a human level,
and it's just so detrimental.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Tom.
TOM VOSS: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Something that really
stuck out to me in the film--
and I'm still
thinking about it even
as I ask you this question--
is Katinka brought this up.
She said, whether you're young
or old, and you go to war,
for a lot of people,
especially young,
that have never
experienced love before,"
that really stuck with me,
because I think that's--
I think that's a lot of the
problem is you don't feel love,
or you've never felt it, if
you've never been in love.
And maybe the connection
is to a parent,
but it's totally different.
Then you come home,
and you fall in love,
or you get into a
relationship with someone,
or you have a child.
And that's the first
time you feel that,
and that flashback
that she spoke about--
I don't know if that
happened for you.
Maybe if it didn't,
you know other people.
But maybe if you can go
into that a little more.
TOM VOSS: Sure.
I mean, I think what we can
really look at is through--
I was in the infantry.
Specifically, I was in
Reconnaissance Battalion Scout
Sniper Platoon.
So there's no room--
and Anthony kind of
touches on this--
there's no room for these other
emotions in our existence.
You have compassion, love,
these different things
that when you're
in a combat zone,
there is just no time to sit
there and analyze things.
You have to react.
And I think that, as to your
point, that's really difficult.
You can't just turn
it on and turn it off.
It's not like a light switch.
So I think that
when you come back,
and you start experiencing,
you're like, OK,
I have to get back into
these relationships,
when the only relationships
I had to worry about
while I was overseas
was the guy or the girl
to the right or left of
me when I was serving.
And there's a much more level
of complexity that happens,
and then you start to
reflect on your deployment.
And I think it took
me about two years
before I even crashed and
burned the first time.
And that's when
relationships started
to deteriorate in my life.
I started pushing people
away, because it was easier
for me to push people
away and out of my life
than to actually have to
address the trauma that I've
been through.
So I think when Katinka
talks about that experience--
and she had interviewed tons
of veterans in the Milwaukee
area--
she was really talking
about these experiences
that veterans are having
and making these connections
when you come home.
And I'm like, OK, now I have--
I call it the
unraveling process.
She's like, OK, what
did I just go through?
How did that impact me?
How has it impacted my family?
And that's when you
start comparing it to,
OK, well, is this who I
really am as a person?
Is this how I was raised?
And then that's where
you have moral conflicts.
And I think it's a
really interesting point
that she made, and it's
really impactful, too.
AUDIENCE: Hi, this question is
for both the filmmaker and Tom.
So I'm curious
about a few things,
so feel free to ignore some of
my questions and answer others.
But overall, it's
about your process
as a filmmaker from beginning
until the film was edited
and released and your process
being documented by filmmakers
and the relationship between the
filmmakers and you and Anthony.
Specifically, I noticed
that in any film,
you have an arc of
a character story.
And so we saw your arc,
and we saw Anthony's arc.
And I'm curious, how much were
you able to film, actually,
of that actual journey
versus what we're seeing?
And where do you feel
that the filmmakers'
presence in your life
impacted you positively?
And also, where you
found it difficult,
both just in what they
were capturing and what
they weren't capturing.
And I noticed you were
quite silent on camera
for a lot of the
beginning of the film.
And I was wondering if
that was an editing choice
or if that was actually what
was going on in your journey.
But Anthony was talking a lot.
TOM VOSS: Anthony talks a lot.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And then-- right.
And then we see this--
he had a pivot point
on the mountain,
and then you had your kind of
pivot [INAUDIBLE] revelation
later on.
But life still continues
also after the film is over.
So I'm also kind of
curious as to now
that the film is no longer--
the filmmaking is no
longer in your journey,
what have been your struggles
since then with the film camera
not there and maybe
where you wish
the camera was still there?
I don't know.
TOM VOSS: Sure you can start.
MICHAEL COLLINS:
Yeah, I'll start.
We weren't there the whole time.
We wanted to-- the most
important thing for me,
honestly, when I
started this was
to make sure that they had the
space to have their experience.
They wanted to go out
and heal themselves,
and already, it was becoming
something a little bit larger.
It was going to
be veterans' trek.
They were raising awareness.
They were having this
kind of campaign.
And then on top of that,
you had a camera crew.
I mean, one good
thing is we didn't
have the budget to stay
with them the whole time.
But honestly, I also
wanted to give them space,
because I'm thinking, there's
a comfortability knowing,
and maybe a little frustration,
when you have a minivan
kind of cruising
along next to you
all day long, because we're
shooting out of the side,
and we're doing
all these things.
But when they have
to be out there
and really are dependent on the
kindness of strangers, I mean,
that's a big deal.
That was something that didn't
make it in the beginning.
They had their packs.
They were like 85, 90 pounds,
and they were so weighed down,
because they were going to
carry everything themselves--
all the food, all
the camping gear,
and then after the
first day, they just
had to unload half of it.
And they're like, we're
going to just have
to depend on other people.
And I think that
was a part of it
was giving them the space to be
out there to face the elements,
to sleep on the side of
the road if they had to,
to be in that silence.
So that was part of the
filmmaking experience.
We'd try to come in
at strategic points.
It was tricky with
a moving target.
But we did our best.
And yeah, in terms of
the edit, of course,
there are choices that are made.
We had 400, 500 hours worth
of footage, and I was nervous.
Tom wasn't really talking.
He wasn't opening up.
And you're like, my main
character isn't talking to me.
And then this other
one won't stop.
So we're on the
plane coming home.
I'm like, what's happening?
Oh, my god.
And then when I finally just
embraced it, I said, that's OK.
That's his journey.
Put the silence on the
screen, him being closed off.
So when Katinka says
it, when she says,
I realized it when he came
home that he was still
emotionally closed off, we're
all thinking, yeah, I know.
We just saw that for the
past 40 minutes as well.
[LAUGHTER]
But in terms of our
relationship, of course,
over time, you're in very
intimate situations with them,
and you care.
You really start to care.
They're people who you're
around all the time,
and you're rooting for them.
And you want them to heal, just
because you become friends.
And to see Tom still
struggling at the end
was honestly very
difficult. I mean,
the filmmaker in me was
like, oh, my goodness, this
is-- it's terrible.
We thought it was just going
to be point A to point B.
But just the human in
me was just heartbroken,
because I was like, he's
not where he hoped to be.
What's going to happen
when he goes home?
I don't know.
So I was really grateful that
he continued on that journey,
that he went to Aspen, that he
did the power breath workshop.
Of course, that means we
had to fundraise some more,
and we had to go
back into production.
But it was all--
it was great.
And then in the
edit, when we watched
Anthony's arc and Tom's arc
go in separate directions,
it made the edit a
lot more difficult.
But it was a lot more
true to the story.
TOM VOSS: And I
guess, for me, it
takes a little getting used
to have a camera in your face
24/7.
So it's easier just to not talk.
It's great.
But no, Anthony and I were--
how it all kind of began
is I was just like,
I need to do something
to decompress.
I haven't addressed
this in 10 years.
I haven't looked at it.
I haven't had the time.
And it was partially my
fault, so I got back,
got my own apartment, got
into school full time,
got a full time job,
just dived right back in,
and I'd crash and burn.
I'd be OK for three
or four months,
and then destroy relationships,
drop out of school,
and pick myself up and restart.
And so that's where it
kind of came out of.
It came out of that necessity
of, OK, I need to do something,
or otherwise, I'm going to
end up like another statistic.
And I've had two guys
from my platoon already,
who've taken their own lives.
So it's very
prominent in my life.
I keep really close tabs on
the guys that I've served with,
and we kind of keep
communicating after those two
events had happened.
But Anthony and I
really thought that we
were going to make our own
documentary with GoPro,
so this was awesome
that Michael found us.
And we're like, thank you.
We don't have to make
our own documentary now,
because we have no
idea what we're doing.
So Anthony really got
into it, though, with,
like setting up GoPros, and we
did some filming on our own,
while Michael wasn't there.
And some of that made the film.
But it takes a lot of
getting used to and kind
of a lot of strength.
As Michael said before,
we walked 20 miles a day,
and when you're in
the Mojave Desert,
where there's 50
mile an hour winds,
you're walking 20
miles a day, and then
Michael pulls up in a
minivan with a camera going
two miles an hour next to
you, it's super motivational.
So no, it's just
how it happened.
So it was an
interesting process,
and it was good to
be a part of it.
And seeing the outcome,
I couldn't be happier,
because Michael wouldn't
even show us footage
that he shot on the road.
He'd be like-- we'd try to
peek, and he'd be like, nope.
And he didn't show us until he
had something similar to what
you guys have seen.
So that was like a year, where
he shot it, and we were like,
we don't know what
this guy's doing.
He was like, he's-- and
Anthony's like, wait.
He's not here.
He's with my family.
He was just like, oh, my god.
What is he asking my family?
So you have this what's going
on back home kind of a thing,
so you just never know
what was going to happen.
But we were both
really, really pleased
with the outcome and amazed
that Michael and Marty
could take this footage,
500 hours of footage,
and make it into
a 90-minute film.
It was pretty amazing.
AUDIENCE: How different do you
think your healing trajectory
would have been if you'd
gone on the journey alone?
TOM VOSS: Yeah, that's
an interesting question.
I don't know--
I don't know if I would
have made it, honestly.
I don't know.
I really don't
know, because what
happened was when Anthony
came along and said,
I want to jump in
on this with you.
Do you mind if I come with you?
And I was like, that's fine.
He had to finagle a
way to make it into,
I need to make this about
work, so I can take off
work for five months.
So we ended up doing a
fundraiser for the nonprofit
that he worked for.
So he's like, OK.
So now we have this walk, the
2,700 miles we have to walk.
Now we have a fundraiser
on top of that,
and then we have Michael making
a documentary on top of that.
So it really just
became this thing.
And we were concerned
at different points
that we're like,
OK, is this going
to take away from our healing?
Is this going to
take away from what
we're trying to accomplish?
And the amount of
support that we
got from the civilian population
or people that didn't know us
was just absolutely amazing.
I think we only had a camp out
maybe 15, 20 times in 155 days.
I mean, there were
so many people
that were supporting
us on social media that
would be like, OK, my cousin
lives in this next town
that you're going to.
You guys can stay with him,
shower, do your laundry,
and they're going to hook
you up with someone else 20
miles down the road.
So we just like leapfrogged
that way with people
just opening up
their doors to us,
which was amazing for us,
because like I said before, we
had that trust issue.
And that really
just blew that away
that there are amazing
people out there
that want to help veterans,
that want to help them heal.
They just need the opportunities
to do it and the direction
in how to do it.
So if I would have
done it by myself,
I wouldn't have
experienced any of that.
I probably would've just been
sleeping in ditches by myself,
honestly.
So yeah, it was good that it
worked out the way it did.
AUDIENCE: Very emotional
movie, so hopefully I
can get through this question.
I am an army mom
of three veterans,
and my youngest has
dealt with PTSD.
So I think this
question will probably
be directed to the doctors.
I learned about moral
injury within the last year,
and it was very impacting to
me, as my son's mother, to--
it just really made sense to me.
And I was very excited to be
able to go home and share what
I had learned about
moral injury with him.
But I'm not seeing that
being used or taught yet
within the VA, and I'm
wondering if our counselors
and social workers,
psychiatrists,
psychologists-- will they be
using or be trained in the more
moral for our veterans?
SHIRA MAGUEN: So I can
start to answer that.
So I think what's incredible
is over the last year
or so, there's been a lot more
education on a nationwide level
about moral injury.
And so we've done some trainings
at the San Francisco VA.
Some people at the Palo Alto
have done trainings, too,
nationally.
There's been a lot of
national recognition
of this issue and a
lot more awareness,
and so I think a lot of
the providers really--
it's now part of the
conversation and part of what
they're getting trained in.
And there are-- even though it's
the conversations are starting,
there's also a lot
of studies right now
that are happening about new
treatments for moral injury
in particular.
And so at our VA, we have
a moral injury treatment
that we use called the
impact of killing treatment.
And it specifically delves
into issues of self-forgiveness
and spirituality and really
exploring all of those areas.
There are other
studies, too, that
are looking at other
treatments for moral injury
to adaptive disclosure,
something called ACT as well.
And so on a nationwide
level, the VA
is moving pretty quickly
to study this, and then
implement some of these
treatments as well.
And so I would say that
if that's something
that you know that your
sons are experiencing,
I hope that you will trust
us enough to reach out
to us so that they can
get some help with that.
And I just want to add,
too, that it's really--
when people come to us, because
of the shame and stigma that
exists, it's often
parents like you
or loved ones that really
bring the people who
need the care most to us.
And so thank you for doing
what you do as a parent
and for all the
parents out there
who are really
helping us to help
people who need it the most.
And that's what we're
really hoping to help with,
and that's what
we're here to do.
So I just wanted to
put that out there.
NATALIE PURCELL: And
if I could just add,
concepts like moral injury
and post-traumatic stress
disorder--
these are terms that emerge in
specific historical contexts.
And if this were the
aftermath of World War I,
we would be talking
about shell shock.
So we come up with
these different terms
to try and capture these very
complicated human experiences
that are both
personal and social.
So the concepts really
do evolve over time,
and I think we're seeing
this evolution, where there's
a recognition that
we need to start
talking about moral injury, as
well as post-traumatic stress
disorder.
And both of those terms are
really only as good as the work
that they do.
Any term, any diagnosis is
only as good as the work
that it does in
terms of helping us
to identify and describe and
respond to and help people,
helping us to
really build empathy
and understanding
for one another.
And so I think it is
really worth asking, why
is it at this moment
that we're starting
to recognize moral injury?
And what is the work that
thinking about moral injury
does at this moment that
just looking at PTSD
alone doesn't do?
PTSD is a medical term.
It's a diagnosis.
It's about the individual.
And when we think
about moral injury,
it's automatically asking
us to think about our values
and about the potential
conflict between personal values
and collective values.
It's asking us to really
look inward to ask
these questions about social
values, about politics.
It raises all of that for us.
And I think that it
also really makes
us have to think about, what are
the circumstances that lead us
to a world where
some people have
to face the extraordinary
stressors and horrors of war,
while most of the rest of us
don't have to face that at all?
And then they come
home and really
have to cope with that,
oftentimes in isolation.
So by thinking about
moral injury, what
is it that we can
do collectively
and socially to
begin to respond?
This is not just an
individual diagnosis.
This is more of a social
issue and a social problem.
AUDIENCE: One of the really
emotional parts of the film
is the mother that
is grieving her son,
and I am just curious if
you discovered that story,
as the film so much suggests,
from the news story,
and then how you
reached out to that mom
and were able to interview
her, that she allowed that?
And then just also,
second part, curious
if you are in contact
with her and what
she thinks of the film.
MICHAEL COLLINS:
Yeah, great question.
It did happen the way,
basically, that you saw it.
I was in a hotel
room with these guys,
and it came up on
the television.
And I was going to Milwaukee
the next day, and at that point,
it was early in the shooting.
It was early in
the journey, and I
knew that I wanted this
film to be about what war
looks like when it
comes home, and I
wanted it to go beyond just
the perspective of the combat
veteran and to include
family stories.
And all of a sudden, I was
on my way to Milwaukee.
She's from Milwaukee.
Her son has the same name as me.
His name is Jeremiah
Michael Collins.
My name is Michael Collins.
It was all these things.
And she was speaking
to the media,
and the last thing I want to
do is call up a grieving mother
and say, hey, can I
come interview you?
That's just about
the last thing I
think anyone would want to do.
But there was something
inside of me that was saying,
she is sharing her
story for a reason,
and maybe you should just try.
So one of my
co-producers, I said, hey,
can you just do a
little outreach?
And very quickly, she found
her number through someone
and was able to get a
message to her, basically.
And she said, yes, please
invite him to call me.
I called her from the airport
the next day as I was on my way
to Milwaukee, and she
was very open to it.
She said, yeah, come.
We were going to have
the services next week.
You should come.
And so we did, and
it was difficult.
It was the most difficult thing,
really, that I've ever shot
and how to handle
that and what is--
how much to put in, how much
to show, what's respectful.
And so it was just a lot of
grappling with that stuff,
while you're shooting, while
you're in the edit room.
But she was really
happy with it.
She's become a friend.
And she used the opportunity
of the film to really share
the fact that her son's
death was a suicide,
because people just
assumed that it wasn't.
And she hadn't come out with
that yet publicly, so she came.
She's come to
screenings in Milwaukee.
We were the centerpiece
of that festival
played to her community.
I think it was an 1,100
seater, something like that.
And she came up
on stage with us.
That was her first time
really coming up and speaking.
She has now gone back to school
to become a social worker.
She's very involved with
TAPS, Tragedy Assistance
Program for Survivors.
So she's moving forward and is
a real big advocate for the film
and doing as well as can
be expected, I suppose.
I wanted to-- and I know
we're probably out of time.
I just wanted to respond, also,
to the question before about
just education on moral injury.
You know, when we
started making the film,
we had a whole campaign in mind.
And one of the pillars
of that campaign
is educating on moral injury.
I think it's that time
right now, where people just
don't know about it, and
that's one of the things,
like as you asked, what's
one of the biggest responses
that you get from people?
They have this aha moment when
they hear about moral injury.
They're like, oh,
that's what it is.
We've had World War II
vets and Korean vets
and all kinds of people
just come up with tears
and say, thank you.
Now I get-- like
something has shifted.
So we've developed all kinds
of educational materials
around this, and we
just started that.
We just started the whole
educational distribution
kind of phase of the film, where
we have it for high schools.
We have it for colleges.
We have it for
institutions, and we're
trying to let people know.
I mean, we're
independent filmmakers,
and we're getting connected
to this whole world.
But if any of you
all want to share
this film with your high
school, with your school,
with an NGO of your choice,
we have ways that you can,
and we'll ship all
those materials.
We also have like
modular content.
Not everyone can sit down
and watch the whole film ,
so we're creating online stuff
and things for high schools,
where they just show
a couple of clips,
and they're able
to talk about it.
And so we've developed a lot of
curriculum around moral injury.
And there's also elements
of the campaign that
are about connecting
communities, about healing,
just these other
modalities of healing,
really pointing people towards
that, and changing legislation.
So I invite you all to
stay connected with us
for social media, but also,
Marty gave me some props,
and he'd be mad at me
if I didn't hold it up.
We have postcards out there that
talk a little bit about this.
If you want to get in touch with
us, you can just come up to me
and talk to me.
I can give you my card,
or you can give me yours.
But you can also fill
this out, and if you
do want to send this
film to your home,
to the library of your
hometown, or if you
want to host a screening at a
school or at an organization,
we'd love to work
with you on that.
These things happen organically,
as you can see, by the way
that Jake invited us here.
So we really depend on you
to keep this campaign going.
And so we also have materials.
So this is kind of
educational, and this
is about corporate screenings.
And come up to us.
Talk to us.
You can fill this out
and hand it back to us,
however you want to do it.
AUDIENCE: I want to ask about
[INAUDIBLE] outreach looked
like.
Sorry.
And I'm so happy that
you're here at Google--
that they're hosting.
But they're kind of the pillar,
the example for corporations
that we hope they achieve
and try to model and mirror.
So I just wanted
to ask about that.
JACOB SOVIERO: Just
so everybody can hear,
the question was about, how do
we take care of our veterans?
And how do we better
treat our veterans,
and how do we
better get involved?
So just so people could
hear you, that's all.
MICHAEL COLLINS: Yeah,
in the corporate setting,
specifically, and I
think that's exactly
like this is the example.
We're at one of the biggest
companies in the world
and bringing people together to
have a conversation is one way.
We've had other models, where
a community bank took the film,
and then they showed it
in 10 different cities.
And they just made it
a gift to that city,
so they invited the local
vets organizations to come
and be on the panel after.
So they announced it,
they rented the theater,
they did all that, and then
they had a conversation
with the community afterwards.
And they said, hey,
here are the services.
These are the vets.
These are the families
that are in your community.
Let's all get together and
have a conversation about it.
And they also made
it a fundraiser.
If anyone wanted to donate,
it would go to that local NGO.
But it was creating
awareness, and it was also
connecting with their community
outside of the business.
So it was showing that
they really cared.
It wasn't just about
dollars and cents,
that it was about the strength
of a community, really.
Businesses reflect that.
So we are able to work with
anyone who is interested in any
of these different models.
If they want to come in
and do something like this,
we're happy to do it.
If a corporation says, hey,
we want to help younger vets,
and we want to sponsor this
film to go to the Student
Veterans of America
chapters across the country,
we have a way that
they can do that, too.
And that's really
meaningful, because when
people are younger, they're
about to go into the workforce.
And they're able to have
these deeper conversations.
They're able to understand
what they're grappling with.
They now know what
is moral injury,
and they can talk about
it with their peers.
So we have all different ways
that we're doing it with this.
Like I said, we are a
film with a campaign,
and we're doing our
best, and we are
creating all these materials, so
they can be used for training.
And we have lesson plans.
We have discussion guides for
communities, for corporations,
for schools, and it really
takes you all reaching out to us
and say, I work here.
I went to this school.
And just come to us,
and let's work together
and make it happen.
JACOB SOVIERO:
Thank you, Michael.
And you brought up a good point,
and I'd like to kind of close
with that one, and we'll
certainly have some time
to mingle afterwards.
But the strength
of the community
is really the important
one, and kind of that's
shown here tonight by all of
you coming out and supporting
this film and
supporting these topics.
And that's the important part.
That's how we get
into businesses.
That's how we make lives change.
So first and foremost,
thank you to the panel--
Michael, Peter, Tom,
Shira, and Natalie.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]